la communauté juif de Marseille est
forte de 75 à 80000 personnes des Juifs
en majorité d'Afrique du Nord en ance
cette communauté est la deuxè de France
après celle de Paris mais ici il n'y a
pas de quartier juif la communauté est
bien intégrée même si certains quartiers
sont préférés à d'autres très unis les
Israélites peuvent pourtant passer pour
des marginaux de par leur
traditions je ne vois pas donc ce qui
pourrait les unir autrement que leur
attachement à la tradition et cette
tradition demeure relativement vivace
dans notre communauté notamment grâce au
fait que cette communauté a connu un
développement numérique considérable
dans les années 62 avec les rapatriés
d'Afrique du Nord dont de très nombreux
sont venus s'installer à Marseille ce
qui fait que pratiquement aujourd'hui
plus de 80 % de cette communauté est
d'origine d'Afrique du Nord sont la
plupart du temps des rapatriés d'Algérie
il y en a aussi de Tunisie et du Maroc
et puis il y a donc dans ces communautés
un très grand attachement au traditions
religieuses qui constitue je crois
indénblement le facteur unitaire de
cette communauté dans le judaïsme la
religion ne repose pas essentiellement
sur le culte un juif qui se veut
traditionnaliste donnera à ses enfants
une éducation spécifique ainsi dans cet
établissement les institutions du CEL
les enfants Israélites reçoivent un
double enseignement classique et
hébraïque c'est ici aussi au cel que
sont formés les futurs cadres de la
communauté et les jeunes
rabins
le colollel c'est une institution qui a
pour but pour vocation euh spécifique de
former des cadres et en particulier des
rabins des jeunes rabins ce sont des
jeunes qui viennent qui sont qui on une
vocation de devenir par la suite
dirigeants de
communauté qui viennentétudier pendant
un certain nombre d'années mais le
colollel est plus que ceci puisque
finalement il est ce que le nom même
indique quelque chose de Global une
globalité
globalité de l'enseignement globalité de
l'enseignement les Juifs sont des gens
il ne faut pas l'oublier qui ne sont pas
venus riches à Marseille loin de là ce
sont des gens qui sont venus je le
disais tout à l'heure par exemple
d'Afrique du Nord sans rien dans les
mains ils ont dû leur réussite sociale
quand c'est le cas à leur travail à leur
Opin tré à leur volonté et je crois que
tout ceci contribue à l'image d'une
communauté juive vivante et très
dynamique également donc au plan euh du
tissu économique marseillais et
limitrophe et pour ces raisons-là je
crois que incontestablement la les
instances par exemple les les disons les
mairies les les conseils régionaux
généraux considèrent généralement la
communauté juive comme un interlocuteur
privilégié cont tenu de la dynamique de
ses
membres